[Music]
who
here is a fan of these oh yeah
oh yeah oh no who's not i love them so
much that me and my friends in
elementary school we would bike
because to the factory it's in gardena
it's in hawaii it's in hawaii and that's
what we're gonna talk about okay
it's it's torrence gardena border right
but i used to live a few blocks from
that so we would get on our bikes
because we knew the times of when it was
fresh to go fresh right so we would bike
over there just to smell it and go
i thought so too you can't you couldn't
buy back then and they didn't have a
so now they have a factory in a
restaurant but when i was growing up
they didn't have that it was just a
factory
they have like hawaiian food yeah and
then they make it out of like
burgers made out of like hawaiian kinks
hawaiian bread all that [ __ ] it's the
[ __ ]
best it sounds like they have gardena
food
yeah so the bottom what about them you
brought up the fact that they're
supposed to be made in hawaii right well
that's what it says
so i thought it was uh originally like
um it was like a restaurant they started
making rolls there
and that's what i think they got bought
out or something well i don't know the
history of it but what i do know
is that this man this man
from uh new york a new york man
is suing kings hawaiian because of the
fact that
they are not hawaiian enough they're not
made in hawaii
they're made they're made in torrance
but doesn't he like the bread though
i'm pretty sure if this new yorker
[ __ ]
destroys king's hawaiian and they're no
longer on the shelves
man i will be very angry
i was like what are you gonna do joe
what are you gonna do from hawaii the
people 2021's a different year and i'm
not gonna make threats online anymore
dude
[Laughter]
anymore very nice any more very nice
that's gross no more violent threats
online when hostess remember everyone's
like hostess is going down it's out of
business and [ __ ]
and then everyone's selling twinkies on
ebay for like three hundred dollars
yeah and then it came back in like three
months
that's a pump and dump dude dude but
that's why i got so many [ __ ] twinkie
boxes at home i'm sitting on my [ __ ]
ass
i'm waiting for this thing to go up
again boy is that a bad purchase
i know they last forever yo but twinkies
in
england are different man my friend
bought a box like this and we were
eating it every day and i was
shocked at how dense it is it's way
heavier
i like that stuff it's more chewier it's
it's not as like
light as ours it's different man is it
better
is it better and your opinion i liked it
better because i like the bite too yeah
it's like more too you don't get full
yeah interesting so this man here from
new york he
filed a class action lawsuit class
action lawsuit so he's saying uh in
federal court by the way and he's
accusing king's hawaiian
of defrauding customers by suggesting
that they're still
made in hawaii because in the in the
first [ __ ] even thinks that
right here right under the name it says
hilo hawaii
the brand thinks that dude i'm coming
after fiji water then are you kidding
well he's an idiot because
all of us know mexico it was
it came from hawaii but all of us know
on the west coast that it's
built in california yeah what does it
say does it say made in [ __ ]
california
um i don't know on the back right but
but the front label the just the mention
of hilo hawaii
to him he's saying that that's already
defrauding customers because you know
corona on the front it says mexico but
then on the back it says like
distributed something illinois or
something maybe he should sue corona
instead
does anybody buy it because of where
it's from i buy it because it tastes so
[ __ ] good
but the way he says it though the way he
says is that
um so it says the prominent placement of
hilo hawaii on the front label
uh coupled with the other legitimate
uses of the word hawaiian is deceptive
and misleading to consumers who believe
they are buying a product made in hawaii
so they're saying that had the plaintiff
and class members
know the truth they would not have
bought the product or would have paid
less for them so they're saying that
they're charging more
for this product because it's being
assumed that it's made in hawaii what is
this guy
that's suing howard if he was a hawaiian
native i'd be like
okay you have the right but to me he
sounds like a new york lawyer that's
found a little way to hurt king's
hawaiian and i don't like that [ __ ]
and if he's so honorable is what he's
asking for just changing
the graphic on the front and not for any
money
no it's a class action lawsuit no so
he's saying what does that mean what's
class action lawsuit even
i spent three dollars i want millions
it's when a bunch of [ __ ] people
get together and they say we're all
suing this entity together
and so yeah give me the names of all the
people who's a part of this who feel
duped by king's hawaiian anyone who's
ever purchased and so the pain would be
in this loss but i'm against this i'm
not gonna i'm not in that
but like if if he loses and kings
hawaiian i mean if king
king's hawaiian loses and they are
required to pay customers and that's
when you get a coupon in the mail for
for three dollars i'll give it back to
kings hawaii so the central point of
pain is when they
have to pay all these [ __ ] people but
mostly they are paying lawyers most
yeah that's the real trick to this yeah
so what they're requesting
guys they're requesting the company
change its label as well as
unspecified damages so that unspecified
damages could be the [ __ ] two dollar
coupon that we
emotional damages and [ __ ] because he
bought a [ __ ] roll of hawaiian bread
and he goes this
[ __ ] loco well maybe he bought the
buns too did you know they have buns now
those are pretty good
bread loafs you can have a hamburger
with a
hot dog it's not as good it's not as
good why is it not as
chewy the buns are more dry that's what
i'm saying yeah they're not as good but
they're still looking at the same
they've got the sweet they've got the
yeah yeah yeah i make burgers with those
you know what you need to do yeah yeah
yeah get four slices oh yeah i put a
little bit i put on the toast a little
bit yep yep yep but now we gotta say bye
to this company because
no we don't you guys are dramatic well
what's over here
it's over yeah it's over it's [ __ ]
done
when a new york lawyer gets his hands on
something they destroy
everything they're [ __ ] you listen
king's hawaiian
is over tim just get it through your
[ __ ] head i refuse to believe no
listen
guys we're gonna make a [ __ ] run on
king's hawaiian rolls royce let's go
[ __ ]
the job yep we're gonna put that [ __ ] on
ebay
i'm gonna make up for my twinkie losses
with this [ __ ] this is what i've been
waiting for you have like a week to sell
them before they become stale
wait is that true i've always ate them
too fast
doesn't mean you eat a whole box to
yourself like like no no no
it's because you buy the big roll where
it's just tied with the zip tie or what
i mean the the [ __ ] twisty
you gotta get the one that's vacuum
packed the fours
and you could get more money out of them
because i never even twisted the twisty
back up i just
roll it up and i put it that's right
that's the true hawaiian way
they don't go stale it works that's what
they do
yeah it's so funny anyways you put it in
the refrigerator because there's so many
dang ads there they [ __ ] rage your
bread
oh [ __ ] really what's the hawaiian bread
that comes with the uh the
metal tin at the bottom too i don't know
i've never seen that same brand but it's
like there's one that's like i don't
know oh
but it's one big roll i think that was
the original
oh oh gee yeah it's like a small pan and
it's
it's not in little buns yeah it's almost
like but it's like a big mountain
oh that one's dude i could sit there and
eat the whole thing it's like the bottom
of a pie
you like the metal thing of a pie it's
like that dude if king's wine is
watching this
you're so [ __ ] by the way but um also
if you guys if you guys can make that
like a sourdough bread bowl but not
sourdough at all just out of the king's
hawaiian
no but sourdough is my favorite if they
somehow mix the two
oh like a sweet kings hawaiian sour
when i make the burgers they kind of
fall apart too quick but they're so
tasty yeah so good
you know what they should do is make the
same rolls
but do it with different flavors like
matcha taro
i do have a matcha hookup if you guys
want today oh that'll be cool
yeah you have savory and sweet yeah yeah
that's kind of cool
what's the whole industry safer but
sweet it's a billion dollar industry
who eats that no you don't like food
though no i don't
my friend does their marketing oh cool
yeah boy's gonna lose his job now
i know right i'm gonna ask
and be like what happened but they're so
like slow well he's not actually
hawaiian probably
but he's probably just finding out now
well the new york guy moves
move stuff huh this new york guy's
probably moving hella fast he needs a
movie he's a shaker he's a cocaine music
that's why i love her dude i want to see
a battle between a hawaiian lawyer
and a new york lawyer and see what that
[ __ ] looks like the guy comes with
you got one that's like super chill and
relaxed versus like
super fasting on coke oh yeah damn who's
gonna win
that's like the turtle in the rabbit
they have to they have to do it in
hawaii
oh he's gonna lose who the hell oh i
should be somewhere neutral
not in the midwest texas well it is
neutral no it is
it sounds like a california company it's
in new york those do in hawaii it's not
any of them i guess you know what i mean
that's true and we go to watch it
and we'll pay-per-view exactly what
would be the most neutral though i would
say alaska
that's all the way that's all the way
out of the way yeah but it's a neutral
area like
like okay if you go on the east coast
it's just not fair because i feel like
new yorkers got you know easily whatever
it's a whole nother reason
if you go west if you go more west i
feel like hawaiian california
kind of like you know similar there's
right now
vegas is like the most neutral place
ever but it's closer to california
it has its own culture from this is
never say yeah i'll meet you halfway
where do you want to go
to joe yeah north dakota north dakota i
think the hawaiian guy
is everywhere no you sure he's just too
chill
i don't know man i feel like that's how
they don't they win with patience
i don't even want them to change the
label how about that yes i like the way
it looks
i want them to add made in hilo hawaii
yeah
double down double down because when i
look at the logo it gives me joy
i know right it makes my mouth water
grass from hilo you know i'm gonna get
that for lunch
so do we know the results of this this
new york guy get run over by a car or
something just the fact that
just the fact that you filed a foreign
personal man this is not only my
childhood but i identify with this like
the bread is my culture what's this new
york guy's name can we cancel no
you ever put pulled pork between oh
jesus
my [ __ ] is sloppy joe's so you know you
get the sloppy joe mix the man witch or
whatever
and then you get ground beef put that
[ __ ] together get one of these bad boys
bam what was it that you were making
because you've made
like different creations sliders sliders
yeah yeah yeah
curry beef oh curry beef my favorite
pork two ones or something yeah pool
pouring i've done all sorts of stuff
have you guys ever put an egg in there
some caramelized onions my first time
taking shrooms and i'll show you guys
the photo is
is mushrooms inside of king hawaii oh
dude we have so much
memory see this is our california
culture man
[ __ ] your new yorkers [ __ ] over
[ __ ] [ __ ] new yorkers want to ruin
california things all the time
i hate new yorkers geez straight up
every single one of them all every
single one of those you guys got the
salami plates
the cheese and salami plates and then
did it with this
you got to do it with this because it's
like an adult version of lunchables well
new yorkers probably sued them for not
being italian enough
[ __ ] man hummus and that's just this one
man already destroyed the entire
everybody you dip that in the al juice
sauce oh [ __ ]
there we go now we're talking mm-hmm i
like that
or baby sliders
i thought it still tastes good like yeah
it's amazing yeah it's probably so much
easier to eat too do you guys like it
toasted
or just the way it is i do one of each
anyway but the burger one a little bit
of toasty little little little bit later
keep the burger yup yup this has to be
warm there's already so much butter you
don't even need butter to toast it you
don't like the crispy outside in the
warm fluffy inside
oh i like it because it turns into a
different animal once you like
toast it's just more work for something
that's already delicious
is it that much more work if you stop
yourself from just putting in your mouth
already yeah
depending on how hungry you are yeah
dude kings hawaiian make the check
payable to jk
films okay because we just [ __ ] sold
your [ __ ] for 13 minutes yup
i'm gonna give me a break hopefully we
save the company i'm gonna send this to
my
brand yeah my marketing buddy tell your
friend that the new yorker's coming
after us i know dude i'm gonna call it
right now
right now
you